maintenant moi je vais me matter c'est
de mettre d'accord tout le monde je suis
pas une minute que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure j'ai un peu mieux aimer ce que
vous avez dit
tiens y'a combien de morts chuck ya
personne qui est capable de répondre si
et combien de morts de la rue cette
année en fait on a un tous les deux
jours ouais non un tous les deux jours
un mort de la rue tous les deux jours
vous n'avez pas moi
la toile à la france est la droite voire
de mort de vente chez toi
ça vous dérange pas de vous dire qu'il
ya des femmes qui accouchent dehors il y
en a qui en profite écoutez un mois et
maintenant profitent même dans tout ce
que vous faites dans la doute votre vie
il ya des gens qui profitent peu importe
près ce qu'ils vont manger au restaurant
ceux qui font ce qu'ils travaillent il
ya des gens qu'il ya des profiteurs dans
n'importe quel truc même mois l'hôtel de
la rue j'ai des gens qui sont venus aux
bmw donc c'est que des moines maternelle
comme
déterminant
quand vous quand j'ai ouvert le talent
de la rue maurice j'ai eu des gens aura
lieu devant chez moi avec des bmw s'est
mis partout il ya des profiteurs j'en
suis conscient que même si les
squatteurs il ya des gens qui squattent
comme chez vous et maintenant les gens
qui a saboté la bmw qui survenu comme
c'est pour vous dire que les squatteurs
partout fier d'eux marc vaurette de mort
tous les jours je me répète sur cette
étrange brièvement parce que j'ai donné
la parole à acquérir et d'eau qu'on aide
les gens qui sont dans la rue évidemment
c'est pour autant je vais pas vous dire
que oui c'est bien d'enfreindre la loi
parce que si on en fera la loi on perd
tous nos repères monsieur la loi mais
non ça va pas on survit louer move and
quoi ton temps la cheville ont
premièrement et de gamme ce qui les a
fait tomber sur le ferai pas eu parfois
ce serait oublier d'envoyer les prive de
tout vous ne mettez plus du tout sur une
fête de considération de mérite je ne
dis pas de faux pas aider les gens dans
la rue vous ne savez même pas quel est
mon engagement personnel par ailleurs
sur ces sujets donc ne me dites pas que
je m'en fous je verrai vous demandez
c'est le verrou et vous ne connaissez
c'est dommage ça se passait bien jusqu'à
mes vignes et donc mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est qu'on ne peut pas
applaudir parce que vous enfreignez la
loi c'est une question de repères par
contre au peuple via côté des hommes qui
meurent dans la rue que la france ne
fait rien mais moi je vends mon pote
était pas mort je n'aurais pas ouverts
l'hôtel de lassay
malek délégué convaincre mon pote il est
mort là l'adjointe du maire madame
dominique dreyssé elle est venue de
pointer devant moi elle a commencé à me
parler ou alors mettre des toilettes
publiques et d'eau des toilettes sèches
il n'y a pas longtemps montagne verte à
strasbourg cent vingt 120 personnes dont
120 quand dans l'auto au tac détente
l'adjoint du maire elle encore venu mais
elle a rien fait s'est il dit se
déplacent les élus la préfète aime quand
même apple aime dire il faut pas faire
de scott a été de deux squats nôtres il
parachevait anime c'est la fête au large
de l'île serait que le tour de table
soit contraire à kehl ouest
les quelque chose qui est important à
dire c'est qu'il ya une très grande
inégalité entre les personnes qui ont du
patrimoine c'est-à-dire qu'ils possèdent
leur logement et les personnes qui n'ont
pas d'autre choix dans la vie que de
payer un loyer sur la base de leur
travail et qu'ils adèle à la seconde où
leurs revenus baissent ils sont dans une
situation de vie ou de mort parce qu'ils
ne peuvent pas de payer de loyer et la
concentration du patrimoine entre
certaines mains pose un problème et
l'utilisation je vais utiliser un mot
qui va vous choquer mais despotique du
droit de propriété par certains pose
aussi un problème parce que vous avez
des entreprises c'est pas vous madame je
pense pas que vous soyez une entreprise
multi rentière avec un appartement mais
je n'y allais autres je ne suis pas un
cas isolé madame c'est ça touche à voir
pardonnez moi si je peux terminer madame
mon exposé il ya des entreprises en
france qui ont un grand parc un grand
parc de logements et qui les laisse vide
parce qu'ils font de la spéculation
parce que pina loin ils pourront ils ont
une vision des comptabilités et puis
disent c'est mon droit de propriété moi
je suis pas d'accord avec ça nous avons
effectivement
collectivement comme nation le devoir de
mettre un toit sur la tête des familles
des enfants des femmes etc et c'est pas
acceptable que des centaines de
logements et de locaux vacants restent
vides des millions aux textes que à bas
la loi la loi pour terminer sur ce point
prévoit un outil que ça s'appelle la
réquisition et ce n'est jamais utilisé
donc moi je veux bien qu'on me dise à la
loi est la loi et je dis bien appliquons
la loi
chez moi si on déloge pardonnez moi mais
ça a été utilisée chez moi le préfet de
police a refusé d'expulser cette
personne ils ont donc réquisitionné mon
logement à titre gratuit
donc oui même les six mois
mais parle de changer à
tout moment a dit que des vodkas s'était
pas sur des bases avaient déjà il est
temps brionne les années il a eu très
peu de temps chez vous plaît chez apple
vous avez
laissé votre caleçon avec vous madame